pumpkin spice latte is like your
everyday drink and this is like let your
freak flag fly social media what do you
like to post to food and the best type
of food is stuff that's original
my god for some reason I was expecting a
big-ass waffle Colin they look a little
small a big guy need a lot of caffeine
to get me going I think they do have
some that are big what is this for know
the rapper so you can't the mess I'm not
gonna make a message I was afraid it
would be too soggy
it smelled dark chocolate like a little
cappuccino in there it's like got foam
on top
it looks like a coffee souffle in a coma
who would not want to Instagram this
it's very grandma thank you God pinkies
out just because I can't even get my
pinky on there for Tommy to it to you oh
that coffee is dead well I mean it is
espresso I've a very low caffeine
tolerance so I'm just like espresso
yourself guys it's pressed for more you
drink it the sweeter it gets cuz all the
chocolates at the bottom is it time for
the crunch it's time for the time oh my
god mm-hmm it has a layer of hard
chocolate once you put the coffee in it
softens it up so you drink the coffee
and you have a little bit of chocolate
in there and then once a bite it's like
warm and smooth you are one of those big
chocolate bottom espresso then just mix
really little 2/3 old you know warm and
gooey and it's just I would very much
like a big cup of this I got another way
to eat your coffee con you have to
finish drinking it before you take a
bite otherwise your meal Oh keep the
trouble you're right
me
that was a goddamn nightmare this is a
really gourmet dish indeed it's not for
the plebeians palate my last not a good
copy don't oh my I don't think I did it
in more camping I'm gonna be hyper on
high Oh smell the Java at the bottom oh
I'm so cool the last bite is the best
bite there's a little drip you see that
oh you got that are you amazing cuz you
have that layer of the like bitter
coffee and then the really melted
chocolate and the crunchy cone fabulous
darling Oh chuck it on my face yeah yeah
step one Instagram it step two get a
napkin cuz it will be all over your face
copy cones a yummy they are so delicious
Robin hates me for saying it but he
enjoyed his to get a copy cone today
[Music]